over the past few weeks there have been
more than 300 allegations of sexual
assault and sexual misconduct against
members of the eSports gaming and
streaming world some of which involve
previously beloved and high-ranking
members of those communities this is a
massive movement working to expose years
of predatory behavior and abuses of
power now I obviously can't cover all of
that in one short video but my hope is I
can at least help you understand what's
going on
in addition to everything all about to
explain to you in this video I urge you
to go up and read and listen to the
people who have come forward with their
stories
because there's just no way you will
understand any of this thoroughly unless
you hear it in their words it's also
worth noting that some of this stuff is
hard to hear
there are graphic accounts of sexual
assault in this video so just a fair
warning if that's something that's going
to be upsetting for you like any
movement with this size and scope it can
be pretty difficult to narrow down
exactly where it started but this
situation really started to pick up
steam on June 20th when allegations were
first made against destiny streamer say
no to rage several women from the
Destiny and twitch communities came
forward with allegations of sexual
misconduct against him this included a
twitter user named mind of snaps who
published a lengthy account of her
interactions with him and accused him of
unwanted touching even after multiple
requests to stop she also included a
video she says she recorded about the
incident on June 15 2019 I'm recording
this because I want if this does come
out I want people to see like the impact
I've been trying to avoid this person
who made me feel incredibly
uncomfortable for a while and I feel
like I just cannot get away from from
their [ __ ] name as each new woman
shared their experience another would
step up and share their story say no to
rage posted video on Twitter responding
to the allegations and apologising that
video has since been deleted two years
ago I was privately made aware that I
had made someone uncomfortable with
inappropriate remarks and behavior this
drove me to immediately come clean to my
wife that I had been living a secret and
self-destructive lifestyle I decided at
moments to go into therapy it needs to
be clearly stated that I am deeply sorry
to anyone hurt or made uncomfortable by
my behavior and since deleting that
original video he published a massive
hour and 15 minute long video on his
youtube channel refuting many of those
allegations made against him the best
way to do this is to carefully walk
through each allegation and provide
evidence that either proves the claims
are false or misrepresented or shown
inconsistency in the claims that I was
unsafe and avoided the labels of sexual
predator harasser and assaulter have
been used to destroy my brand and more
importantly Who I am as a person and as
the say no her age situation snowballed
the floodgates opened people from all
over the gaming world stepped up and
shared similar experiences with other
ranking members of the gaming community
over the course of the weekend more than
50 accusations were made and it became
clear that this wasn't an isolated
incident it wasn't limited to one game
one platform or one community and then
on June 21st allegations of sexual
assault and sexual misconduct were made
against youtuber Pro syndicate you'll
probably recognize his name from his
role in the csgo skin gambling
controversy back in 2016 I passed it off
as them just being a shitty person and
because of their power and their
position I tried to maintain you know a
friendly relationship with them until
one day I just like cut them off and was
like I'm [ __ ] done with this after
that video was posted by streamer the
zombie unicorn another user on Twitter
Caitlin Witcher posted her own video
explaining her experience with Pro
syndicate where she alleged that he'd
forced alcohol on her and sexually
assaulted her multiple times the first
time things started happening he told me
to be quiet and that I was supposed to
like it and so I thought he was right
because I didn't know any better because
I had never dated someone before person
to get quickly tweeted that he was
shocked by these allegations and that he
would have a larger statement on each of
the individual claims later on On June
24th he came out with that larger
statement refuting all the claims and
calling them a character assassination
here's a quote from the statement quote
this is a character assassination by
social media without evidence to support
it or any justification these two women
have chosen to make horrendous
allegations against me for reasons I do
not understand attempting to stage a
public trial without giving me a chance
to defend myself
unquote during that initial wave of
allegations that included syndicate
World of Warcraft he method star healer
method Josh also had allegations made
against
Josh was accused of sexual harassment by
multiple women including some who were
minors at the time of the alleged
incidents in a twit longer titled my
experience with method Josh a woman on
Twitter named Alex may accuse Josh of
engaging in online sexual activity with
her when she was 16 and another person
accused Josh of quote grooming her when
she was 14
since these allegations method released
a statement releasing Josh from the
roster but that was met with even more
allegations that method knew about
Josh's behavior beforehand and never did
anything about it
it was the rape thing it was the girls
that came forward it was the anonymous
email it was the problems that Blizzard
had with them it was the fact that he
got banned on twitch for it it was the
fact that he was being creepy to girls
on stream it was the knife like there
was it was [ __ ] seven or eight or ten
different things and it wasn't just one
thing that would have been a mistake
after the initial wave of allegations
against Josh further allegations were
made against method co-founder sasha
Stephan's and another method player
fragrance since all this has come to
light both sponsors and streamers have
left method including popular streamer s
fan on that same day that syndicate was
first being accused June 21st
twitch released a statement on what was
quickly becoming an insurmountable
number of accusations and to say that
twitch community members weren't buying
the company's supposed sincerity would
be an understatement twitch streamer
Starling continued to pile on the
criticism against twitch when she
described this alleged comment from
Twitter CEO quote the CEO of twitch
Emmett shear was asked in an all-hands
meeting about partners using their
platforms to fuse women specifically
using my case as an example he chuckled
said quote wow the things that go on on
our platform can't really comment end
quote and then moved on now this
rejection of Twitch's stance was not an
isolated incident it contributed to a
organized blackout on Twitch On June
24th the same day that method Josh was
accused also that incident I previously
mentioned with twitch CEO wasn't the
only accusation made against a
high-ranking twitch staff Twitch's
accounts director of strip
he took partnerships Hassan Bukhari was
also accused of sexual assault by twitch
streamer viable one of the other major
sets of allegations made during that
first wave were against a man named Omid
dari on the CEO of Opie group ob group
is a management company that represents
content creators across the internet
including YouTube and twitch the initial
accusation made by a twitter user named
Mally alleges that Omid used his
powerful position in the streaming
industry to pressure her into a sexual
encounter with him and his wife in her
statement she says he was quote you were
being manipulative to young woman who
looked up to you you used your position
of power and stories about quote
blacklists to pressure me into having
sex with you end quote after Molly
statement streamer OD games also
contributed in an account of an
experience she'd had in O Meads home
during which other unnamed members of
the gaming community allegedly sexually
assaulted her and a friend in a hot tub
after these allegations became public
Omid resigned from his position as CEO
at obg and issued an apology on Twitter
since these allegations have come to
light many of Opie G's clients have left
the company including Co carnage Dodger
stripping and tally now like I said I'm
really just scratching the surface here
well I'm telling you these stories about
all these big names who have been
accused other allegations were coming up
the whole time you know we're talking
going from fifty to a hundred
allegations in just a few days now until
this point I've been walking you through
just a few of the allegations made
against streamers and people in
positions of power in the twitch space
but it didn't take long for people in
the eSports world to also have to reckon
with allegations of sexual misconduct
and sexual assault and on June 25th a
twitter user named meruna posted a twit
longer with the caption Toby Wan
wouldn't take no for an answer in the
post she accuses dota 2 caster tobe one
of quote initiating sexual activity with
me against my clear and repeated wishes
and quote after that initial accusation
Toby wants casting partners syndrome
who's been maroon as longtime boyfriend
and capitalist both said that they would
no longer work with him valve also took
action and immediately removed
Toby wands voice lines
the International tag battle class
beyond the summit and his agency Code
Red eSports also cut ties with Toby
Warren in response to the allegations
Toby released this statement and
announced his retirement on July 2nd
quote I've always said that influencers
are held at a higher level and criticism
is something we all accepted but after
this experience it has turned to
something more toxic this is not
something I ever want in my life or
especially to have any effect on my
family as of this post I will cease to
have any public image in eSports
I will never commentate again and my
focus will turn fully to my family and
finding a way to move on with my life
end quote
now Toby Wan wasn't the only member of
the dota 2 casting community to have
allegations made against one woman said
that grand grant another caster who
casted TI 8 grabbed her and allegedly
wouldn't let her go during a TI 7
after-party another woman and cost
player named wicked cosplay tweeted
another allegation on behalf of a woman
who wished to remain anonymous
within that account grant was accused of
allegedly drugging and sexually
assaulting the anonymous woman during TI
4 in response to all of these
allegations grant made the following
statement and also retired from casting
dota within a matter of days two members
of the casting team in the biggest
tournament in all of eSports the
International have retired from their
jobs due to allegations of sexual
assault in the days following that
situation two dota this movement struck
the streaming world even heart fed
Meister or you might omus fed a streamer
and youtuber that makes content in the
offline TV house was accused of sexual
misconduct with multiple housemates the
original accusation came from Yvonne
another content creator within the
offline TV house who posted a twit
longer containing multiple allegations
against fed Yvonne alleged that fed came
into her room in the middle of the night
drunk multiple times and inappropriately
touched her in response to her post
offline TV removed fed from the house
and cut ties with him following the
situation pokeyman shared her entire
perspective on the situation
on stream I want to put a huge emphasis
on this the way he [ __ ] talked Yvonne
and Lily to me and others is so
frustrating no
what happened between them the Yvan
incident happened and Fed would start
talking to me I'm so sorry for being
motional he would talk to me about how
Yvan was lazy and not working enough and
playing league all the time and I was
concerned when in reality her behavior
was entirely because of the incident
that happened between them - after he
was removed from the house Fed made this
apology on Twitter that didn't deny any
of the accusations but did say that he
never intended to hurt anyone and that
he was going to try to do better in the
future and that brings us to right now
when I'm filming this video there have
been more than 300 allegations of sexual
assault and misconduct in the gaming and
streaming world and this situation just
hit the smash and fighting game
community hard top player nairo and
commentators senpai Kotaro and d1 an Evo
co-founder mr. wizard all had their own
set of allegations made against them in
the same day smash ultimate player
puppies twit longer alleges that he had
a sexual relationship with sin PI when
puppy was 14 and sin PI was 24 members
of the fighting game community
immediately started tweeting about an
organized boycott of this year's evo
after the specific allegations made
against co-founder mr. wizard he was
alleged to have on multiple occasions
pressured young boys into removing their
clothes after that evil released a
statement saying that Wiz had been put
on administrative leave and then on July
2nd evil announced that this year's
event has been cancelled in the days
following Evo being cancelled legendary
smash player zero was also accused of
sexual misconduct with minors an artist
who goes by Jisoo artist on Twitter said
that zero was quote you were showing me
explicit craigslist ads of sex workers
and hentai on the big screen and
constantly harassing me at the sky host
when I was 15 end quote another
accusation came from a brand new Twitter
account under the name Katy that alleged
serie was setting her sexually charged
messages and asking her for explicit
photos when she was 14 it's also been
alleged that zero has shared porn with
minors in his personal discord server
since these allegations were made public
zero released a statement addressing
each one independently saying that he
wants to take ownership for his actions
he also admitted to sending what he
called horrendous messages to Katy when
he was 19 and she
14:00 I'm gonna read you part of his
statement quote moving forward I want to
take this time to self-reflect and
improve myself as a person I always
wanted to inspire people and be a beacon
of reason I failed and I've made
terrible mistakes that I deeply regret I
want to learn to be a better person one
day I'm so sorry to everyone involved he
also added that effective immediately he
was banning himself from all smash
events since the release of his
statement on Twitter many have called it
into question including jisu she
released a Google Doc where she
collected more allegations against zero
including asking Katie for sex after he
knew she was underage and offering to
fly someone out to an event so they
could meet in person when she was also
underage tempo storm zeros org and
Facebook gaming where he signed an
exclusive deal to stream have both
dropped him now the cases I've just
named are just a handful of the more
than 3-hundred accusations that have
been made over the past few weeks I can
quite literally sit here for hours and
not be able to get through everything
it's quite clear that there's a problem
here it's not just a few bad apples or
whatever people like to say there is an
institutional problem here I hope this
brief synopsis can help you understand
what's been going on over the past few
weeks but I can't tell you the whole
story for that you're gonna have to
watch these videos and read these twit
loggers in order to properly understand
what's going on here it has to come from
the victims not just a third party like
me my intention is to help amplify those
voices not replace them so go and make
the effort so you can actually try to
understand what these people who have
come forward are going through hundreds
of them